وصفاء مساعد الامين العام لشؤون الشرق
الاوسط واسيا والمحيط الهادئ خالد خياري
زيارتها وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ايتامار بنج فير للاماكن المقدسه وصفها
بالتحريضيه لانه دعى الى تغيير الوضع
تاريخي في القدس وخلال جلسه طارئه لمجلس
الامن لبحث التطورات في القدس المحتله
اضاف المسؤول الاموي وان الوضع في الاماكن
المقدس وان اي حادث يمكن ان يؤجل العنف في
المنطقه
والد فيزه وزنه اكونت زياره لم تكن مصحوبه
او متبوعه بالعنف الا انه ينظر اليها على
انها تحريضيه بالنظر الى دعوات بنغفير
السابقه الى تغيير الوضع الراهن ان الوضع
في الاماكن المقدسه في القدس
المحتله واسرائيل واماكن اخرى في المنطقه
مع اخذ هذا الواقع في الاعتبار يجدد دعوه
الامين العام لجميع الاطراف الى الامتناع
عن الخطوات التي يمكن ان تصاعد التوتر في
الاماكن المقدسه وحولها وان يحافظ الجميع
على وضع الراهن